bonsoir à tous cette salle de
pont-à-mousson et plein merci monsieur
le maire merci cher henri d'être
toujours là au rendez vous de nous
accueillir dans cette salle de
pont-à-mousson dans cette belle ville
entre nancy et metz et je voudrais
remercier laurent wauquiez le remercier
lui rendre hommage et lui dire combien
le travail de fond qu'il a fait pour
reconstruire notre famille politique la
rebâtir alors que nous avons perdu l'un
perdable alors que la défaite que nous
avons subie à l'élection présidentielle
de manière historique fait que nous
avons évidemment crée de la déception il
y a fallu rebâtir cette famille et si
vous êtes là aujourd'hui c'est parce que
partout dans les territoires nous sommes
mobilisés
laurent est un président qui fait le
boulot qui a mis les mains dans le
cambouis et si ça se voit peut-être pas
dans le travail ou dans médiatique dans
ce qu'on veut voir
d'un point de vue médiatique moi je peux
vous dire que sur le terrain dans nos
fédérations ça se voit alors je voudrais
remercier aussi tous les présidents de
fédérations qui sont là au premier chef
éric pense elle finit qui est le
président de la fédération de
meurthe-et-moselle
tous les présidents de fédérations les
quatre départements de la lorraine mais
aussi les secrétaires départementaux
les délégués de circonscription oui
bravo patrick les délégués de
circonscription tous nos cadres les
républicains qui participent à cette
reconstruction de notre famille les élus
les parlementaires qui sont ici présents
nombreux les conseillers régionaux
les conseillers départementaux et vous
les militants ceux qui ont des
convictions à défendre ceux qui
s'engagent au quotidien
et quel que soit votre âge du plus jeune
des plus jeunes ont peut-être plus âgé
parce que claude blick qui doit être
dans cette salle il est là
claude il a allez levez vous claude
levée
on vous voit levé vous allez levez vous
allez claude claude licka 81 18 ans il
est le doyen de cette assemblée et il
est avec nous et hilare il ira voter
pour les républicains
merci claude merci d'être là merci merci
d'être tous là parce que vous savez on a
un président de la république qui
voudraient nous effacer qui
souhaiteraient que les républicains
n'existe plus qu'il y ait juste un match
entre le front national et lui il
voudrait que la démocratie se résume à
un duel et ils voudraient nous enfermer
dans un étau eh bien vous êtes la force
qui démontre que les républicains existe
que les républicains sont engagés dans
une vraie dynamique pour ces élections
européennes et que les républicains
n'ont pas encore dit leur dernier mot
sur cette échéance il nous reste dix
sept jours et laurent wauquiez au delà
d'avoir rétabli notre famille politique
il a eu la judicieuse idée parce que
nous en avons parlé
la judicieuse idée de se dire pour cette
élection européenne
j'ai plusieurs possibilités
il aurait pu choisir morano qui avait
fait un très bon score dans la région
grand s il aurait pu choisir arnaud
danjean qui est spécialiste des
questions de sécurité
il aurait pu choisir une autre
personnalité et il a voulu tenter le
défi de choisir
françois-xavier bellamy je vais vous
dire je vais être franche entre renault
je ne le connaissez pas
et laurent le 10 mai rencontre le tu vas
voir si franchement il est très très
bien il est venu me voir comme il est
allé voir d'autres responsables
politiques et je me suis dit mais quelle
chance d'avoir une personnalité comme ça
qui vient qui s'engagent et qui vient
nous rejoindre c'est un défi difficile
d'être tête de liste dans une élection
européenne
c'est un enjeu majeur il le sait il est
parti dans cette campagne avec un sac à
dos lourd lourd des déceptions de nous
avions suscité engendré chez nos
compatriotes et qui au jour après jour
au cours de cette campagne déleste ce
sac parce que il arrive à convaincre
parce qu'il allie arrive à séduire et
qu'au fur et à mesure eh bien nous
voyons que françois-xavier bellamy va
arriver au sprint final bien léger mais
fort de toutes nos convictions forts de
nos forces port du travail que nous
ferons sur nos territoires pour faire
gagner la liste des républicains alors
vous savez cet enjeu
il est majeur pourtant on voit bien que
monsieur macron a essayé de stériliser
le débat nous sommes à 17 jours de cette
échéance est depuis des semaines et des
mois on voit que nous sommes enfermés
dans le grand débat le grand blabla les
grandes par lot est d'ailleurs dans le
programme de monsieur macron porté par
madame loiseau ils vont aussi faire une
grande conférence européenne pour pour
rebâtir l'europe
en fait il veut exporter son grand
blabla au delà des frontières
eh bien nous nous n'en voulons pas et
puis c'est quand je quand je vous
regarde dans cette salle je comprends à
quel point vous pouvez être motivé par
ce que j'ai lu la presse
évidemment ce matin et comme vous comme
beaucoup je découvre que monsieur macron
va rembourser va rembourser la cg
qu'il a pris dans la poche des retraités
alors rappelez vous sur le plateau de
monsieur jean pierre pernaut vous aviez
monsieur macro qui disait avec beaucoup
de culot
mais je dis merci aux retraités merci
parce qu'ils devront faire un effort
on leur des zeks les retraites on leur
colle une augmentation de la cg mais je
leur dis merci
et bien moi avec ce que j'ai lu ce matin
j'ai envie de dire au président macron
qu' il faudrait qu'il demande pardon aux
français
pardon ont retraité de leur avoir pris
de l'argent dans les poches pour se
rendre compte qu'il a fait une grosse
erreur et d'ensuite d'aller les
rembourser et bien quand je vois ces
neuf millions de retraités qui ont perdu
en pouvoir d'achat
quand je vois qu'au quotidien c'est la
cible du gouvernement
mais je voudrais juste dire dans ces
pays
dans ce pays la lorraine en cette terre
de lorraine qui incarne aussi le travail
l'industrie bien que franchement les
retraités qui touchent leur retraite
ce n'est pas une allocation c'est un dû
c'est un dû et que les retraités
aujourd'hui ceux qui sont à la retraite
maintenant ils n'ont pas travaillé 35
heures ils ont travaillé beaucoup plus
ils ont fait pour beaucoup ici les trois
huit
ils ont fait du travail difficile elle
leur retraite
elle est méritée alors je le dis
monsieur macro demander pardon et
surtout ne recommencez pas à toucher au
pouvoir d'achat des retraités
on a écouté ta ça on va pas se mentir ça
fait deux ans que le président de la
république est élu
ça fait quasi six mois que la france est
dans le chaos que nous sommes et on le
voit bien que ce gouvernement est
incapable de résoudre la crise sociale
des gilet jaune qu'il est incapable
aujourd'hui de rétablir véritablement la
sécurité et que les français se demande
chaque samedi dans quelle ville et ça va
casser dans quelle ville ça va cogner et
ça c'est la démonstration que nous avons
aujourd'hui au pouvoir un président qui
a simplement été élu par défaut alors
moi ce que je ne voudrais pas c'est
d'avoir aussi à l'europe des députés
européens dont on voit la constitution
de la liste de madame l'oiseau qui
associe monsieur qu'enfin avec l'ancien
président des gia qui apprécient qui
associe des personnalités ou aux propos
contradictoires et dont les propositions
ne vont pas dans l'intérêt de la france
pourquoi je vous dis ça parce que je
savais ce qu'il va se jouer le 26 et
j'ai été étonné parce que
françois-xavier bellamy hier et état
d'une émission de radio hier matin j'ai
écouté avec beaucoup d'attention
c'était le jour du 8 mai nous fêtions la
capitulation de l'allemagne nazie et au
cours de ces commémorations et bien ce
qui sont importantes pour nous les
journalistes n'ont pas absolument pas
dit un mot a francisé bellamy sur ce qu
est la clé de voûte en fête de l'europe
c'est-à-dire la paix alors heureusement
françois xavier a su placer cette france
va bientôt n'est aujourd'hui c'est
important
c'est le 8 mai 45 alors si j'ai demandé
à claude qu'à 98 temps de se lever et de
le remercier de sa présence c'est aussi
pour ceux qui sont derrière nous pour
tous ces jeunes parce que vous voyez
dans cette campagne on ne parle pas
beaucoup de la paix mais moi
j'appartiens à la première génération
qui n'a pas connu la guerre
ma mère m'a raconté la guerre nos grands
parents nous en raconter la guerre mais
moi j'appartiens à cette première
génération qui n'a pas connu tout comme
mes enfants ne la connaissent pas et
comme je voudrais que mes petits enfants
ne la connaissent pas non plus alors on
a l'impression que c'est rien mais moi
je peux vous
dire que être dans un territoire de 500
millions d'habitants qui vivent en paix
et bien c'est devenu un exploit et ça
c'est le message des pères fondateurs ou
nathalie colin oesterlé a eu raison de
rappeler que nous sommes ici en lorraine
sur la terre de schumann et que les
pères fondateurs de l'union européenne
se sont dits plus jamais ça et ce
message il est important parce que c'est
un devoir que nous avons à transmettre
cette paix mais au fond qu'est l'europe
voulons nous et quelle europe
allons nous proposer à nos compatriotes
nous nous savons ce que nous voulons
nous nous ne voulons plus
d'élargissement nous considérons qu'à 28
eh bien nous sommes assez dans cette
europe nous considérons que c'est déjà
même beaucoup et que cette construction
européenne
si nous n'y prenons garde eh bien il est
déjà tellement fragilisé qu'elle
pourrait imploser l'intérieur donc plus
d'élargissement nous sommes clairs là
dessus monsieur macron ne l'est pas nous
ne voulons pas d'élargissement et nous
disons très clairement à la turquie est
ce que vous avez entendu monsieur macron
être clair sur ce sujet la turquie n'a
rien à faire dans l'union européenne
nous sommes nous clair et précis quand
nous parlons de ce qui nous semble
essentiel est ce que françois-xavier
rappelle régulièrement à savoir la
civilisation européenne défende nos
valeurs nos racines nos racines judéo
chrétiennes sans avoir peur de le dire
et de le revendiquer
parce que vous venez vous et allez à la
cathédrale notre dame de reims 1 mais en
france il y à 40 mille lieux de culte
chrétiens et ça c'est notre histoire
c'est notre patrimoine qu'on soit
croyant ou pas croyant eh bien la france
a des racines chrétiennes
notre civilisation européenne aussi il
faut le revendiquer il faut avoir la
volonté de l'inscrire dans notre été
pour dire à ceux qui veulent venir chez
nous qui nous sommes enfin
nous avons dans cette région de lorraine
terre de jeanne d'arc terre de verdun
terre d'élection aussi choisi par
philippe séguin terre de antoine veil
terre nantua les nouvelles je te cherche
ac
jacques lamblin le maire de lunéville
terre d'emploi nouvelle puisque le mari
de simone veil étaient du lunévillois et
nous avions beaucoup de discutions
ensemble avec simone et antoine bell
j'ai eu l'honneur d'aller d'ailleurs à
leur domicile parisien nous nous sommes
rencontrés à de nombreuses reprises et
je sais à quel point elle était attachée
elle aussi à notre civilisation à ce que
nous voulions en faire et quelle a été
la première femme présidente du
parlement européen
alors nous avons des fragilités il faut
le dire
donc nous nous voulons remédier à ces
fragilités nous voulons le faire parce
que si nous avons créé l'espace schengen
de libre circulation des personnes et
les biens auxquels nous l'aura nous
sommes attachés nous sommes une région à
trois frontières
nous sommes attachés à cette libre
circulation des personnes et des biens
mais nous voulons pour que cela
fonctionne correctement sécuriser nos
frontières extérieures de l'europe
ceux qui viennent chez nous et bien
doivent pouvoir demander l'asile
avant de mettre un pied sur le sol
européen
je sais au parlement européen je suis
membre de la délégation en charge des
relations avec le parlement panafricain
le discours que tient devant vous je le
tiens en afrique de la même manière
jeudi les bateaux en provenance du
continent africain ont vocation à
retourner vers le continent africain
les demandes d'asile doivent être
déposées sur le continent africain
et je le dis aussi parce que j'ai vu que
dans le programme dangereux d'ailleurs
de madame l'oiseau il voulait faire un
pacte pour l'afrique mais vous savez que
chaque année nous donnons 17 milliards
d'euros pour le développement de
l'afrique 17 milliards d'euros par an et
donc moi je veut conditionner ses aides
à l'afrique
en contrepartie de leur maîtrise de leur
immigration et à ce qu'ils reprennent
aussi leurs ressortissants arrivé en
situation illégale sur notre territoire
la réalité c'est que les européens ne
peuvent pas payer deux fois
ils ne peuvent pas payer pour le
développement en afrique et payer une
seconde fois pour vous aider ceux qui
sont arrivés en situation illégale sur
notre territoire
ça n'est pas possible et pourtant
pourtant le développement de l'afrique
est un enjeu majeur
est ce que vous savez que nous français
nous représentons 0 85% de la population
mondiale même pas 1% que si nous sommes
seuls comme voudraient le faire le front
national c'est à dire recroquevillés sur
nous-mêmes mais nous serons désemparé
faible en veille
notre force c'est d'être unis notre
force c'est d'être unis mais c'est
d'avoir aussi notre propre politique
migratoire
parce que je le dis les français doivent
pouvoir choisir qui vient sur son
territoire les français doivent pouvoir
choisir qui vient sur leur territoire et
ceux qui respectent nos coutumes nos
lois parce que quand on veut venir en
europe
on ne vient pas en apportant sa culture
je veux que nous ayons à discours ferme
contre l'islam radical
je veux que nous ayons un discours ferme
sur l'immigration parce que ceux qui
vous disent que c'est une forme de
générosité net à mal la dignité humaine
combien de bidonvilles avons-nous
maintenant en région parisienne plus
d'une centaine est ce que la dignité
humaine c'est de voir des gens vivre
dans la rue de manière déplorable et et
ça n'est pas acceptable ce n'est pas
acceptable non plus de voir des jeunes
arrivés du continent africain qui sont
hébergés dans nos centres celui de
vendeuvre et surchargé on a ouvert
l'office national des forêts avec as
avec un centre dédié aux jeunes arrivés
d'afrique subsaharienne
eh bien ça n'est pas possible parce que
ceux qui viennent d'afrique notamment
des pays qui ne sont pas en guerre comme
la côte d'ivoire comme le mali comme le
cameroun doivent repartir chez eux il y
à une directive européenne qui est la
directive dite retour parce qu'on parle
souvent de sueur transposition il
faudrait aussi qu'on parle aussi de
l'asu transposition parce que cette
directive permet le retour des mineurs
non accompagnés
s'ils sont accueillis chez eux par un
centre d'accueil par un membre de leur
famille ou para tuteur alors moi je vais
vous dire il faut que nous soyons fermes
les français attendent de nous une
europe sécurisé par leurs frontières
une europe dans laquelle on respecte le
travail et je terminerai par un mot vous
savez nous sommes allés avec avec
laurent wauquiez rencontrés avec
monsieur le maire de pont-à-mousson
rencontré l'intersyndicale de
saint-gobain
il y a un thème essentiel pour nous
c'est que nous ne pouvons plus laisser
l'europe l'union européenne ouvertes à
tous les vents
quand je vois que les dents une
possibilité de voir un rachat par les
chinois de saint gobain dites vous que
toutes les canalisations qui assure
l'eau potable qui est stratégique pour
nous et que toutes les plaques que vous
avez vu la raison de le dire il n'y a
pas un pays on n'a pas une plaque pam
sur sur les sols les plaques d'égout moi
je crois que c'est important de dire
maintenant stop on a des clauses qui
nous permettent de protéger les
investissements étrangers sur notre
territoire on doit se protéger
on doit prendre des mesures qui
permettent de protéger nos emplois et
moi je ne veux plus de concurrence
déloyale
je veux la réciprocité commerciale
je ne veux plus que nous qui sommes
ouverts en termes de marchés publics à
95% nous ayons comme la chine un pays
qu'il ne s'ouvre pas qui est à 0% sur
les marchés publics
les etats unis qui protège ses marchés
et nous ne protégeons pas eh bien il
faut changer de méthode
nous voulons protéger nos emplois nos
industries et pour cela il faudra que
nous ayons une politique de contrôle les
investissements étrangers
c'est ce qu'a fait d'ailleurs alain
proust à l'initiative de notre
présidente délégation au parlement
européen et je voudrais aussi saluer mon
ami arnaud danjean qui est spécialiste
des questions de sécurité qui fera
équipe avec nous dans cette nouvelle
aventure
enfin je vais en terminer par un dernier
mot tu me permets c'est pour toi
disons que vous avez mis les spots fait
cholin ouais c'était en fait c'est pour
nous faire disparaître de la scène alors
non mais je voudrais dire un mot sur
geoffroy didier parce qu'aujourd'hui il
fait le monsieur qui accueille et
geoffroy didier vous le voyez à la télé
souvent sur les plateaux et moi j'ai
toujours défendu même sa candidature sur
la liste aux élections européennes
la dernière fois parce que je trouvais
que c'était un garçon qui était très
talentueux et je trouvais qu'il était
très talentueux mais je le pense encore
aujourd'hui
il est au parlement européen
il y reviendra et je m'en réjouis alors
je voudrais vous dire simplement ici
vous êtes allé mille dans cette salle
c'est bien mais j'ai besoin que chacun
d'entre vous à convaincre ou moins ou
moins 10 personnes
prenez vos calepins regardez vos amis
votre famille vos proches vos voisins
mais à les convaincre
parce que moi ce que je veux c'est que
françois-xavier bellamy 1 dans la
dernière ligne droite et bien il nous
gris emmanuel macron et la liste de
nathalie loiseau parce que quand on
nouvelle quand on nous met en troisième
en troisième position mais moi je vais
vous dire que c'est pas la place de la
droite et du centre
alors je veux bien qu'on tente de nous
effacer mais je pense qu'avec françois
et les bellamy est avec vous tous
on va réussir on va faire gagner cette
liste pour les élections européennes
nous ferons gagner les républicains et
surtout nous ferons gagner nos
convictions pour la france au sein du
parlement européen
nous devons revenir avec une délégation
forte c'est entre vos mains que ça se
passe c'est votre travail c'est votre
énergie
j'ai confiance en vous dipanda mousson
vive la france et vive l'europe
[Applaudissements]